er lässt sich nicht vom Hof jagen Armin
Laschet will weitermachen und den
Prozess der Erneuerung seiner Partei
moderieren viele hatten heute mit seiner
Rückzug gerechnet aber der wahlverlehrer
setzt überraschend weiter auf Jamaika
während SPD FDP und Grüne entspannt
Gemeinsamkeiten ausloten hat eine
Regierung mit der Union wirklich noch
eine Chance ist das Realitätsverlust
oder ein Abgang mit Anstand Verwirrung
um Laschet Rückzug auf Raten unser Thema
jetzt in der phönix-runde
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus Berlin ich darf Ihnen
unsere Gäste vorstellen bei mir ist
waldemar Hartmann sie kennt nee das ist
nicht Waldemar da ist er sie kennen ihn
als Sportmoderator aber er hat vor allem
auch die CDU im Wahlkampf unterstützt
deshalb ist er heute Abend hier und sie
sind Mitglied der
Mittelstandsvereinigung der Union miet
herzlich willkommen hallo und ich
begrüße Albrecht von Lucke
Politikwissenschaftler und Redakteur der
Blätter für deutsche und internationale
Politik herzlich willkommen susanne
Gaschke Journalistin und Publizistin
unter anderem für die Welt sie hat
zuletzt eine Biografie über Robert
Habeck verfasst und sie war auch lange
Mitglied der SPD und auch mal Kieler
Oberbürgermeisterin herzlich willkommen
einen schönen Abend und jetzt Wiegand
Salazar wir haben sie eben schon gesehen
Unternehmens und Kommunikationsberater
und Deutschland Chef der MSL Group
herzlich willkommen
das waren verwirrender Tag heute alle
haben ja damit gerechnet weil es gab
dann Meldungen es gab heute eine
virtuelle Fraktionssitzung und deshalb
gab es Meldungen dass man damit rechnen
würde dass Armin Laschet zurückziehen
würde eine personelle Neuaufstellung
solle es geben und dann trat Armin
Presse und hat gesagt er glaubt noch an
Jamaika und er will diesen Prozess
moderieren aber er will auch nicht im
Weg stehen wie muss man das alles
verstehen naja der zweite Teil war der
eigentlich entscheidende er hat in der
Tat noch einmal deutlich gesagt übrigens
ganz anders als Markus Söder der ja eine
ganz entscheidende Rolle bei diesem
Rückzug auf Raten wie sie zu recht sagen
gespielt hat der ja gestern Jamaika
faktisch beerdigt hat und damit
eigentlich die große Karte die Chance
für Armin Laschet abgeräumt hat die
Hoffnung dass es doch noch zu einer
solchen Konstellation kommt dem hat
Laschet nachdem übrigens auch viel
natürlich in der eigenen Partei der CDU
gedrängt haben heute Wolfgang Bosbach
eine ziemlich unabhängige Stimme in der
Bild-Zeitung klar gesagt hat Armin
Laschet zieht die Konsequenzen trete ab
in Ehren damit war der Druck in der
Partei offen sich so stark im Kessel
dass er jetzt eine Doppel Taktik quasi
vollzogen hat der einerseits gesagt ja
ich stehe weiter als Ansprechpartner für
Jamaika zur Verfügung ich mache das
Angebot das ist ja mittlerweile da
stehende Wort aber wir können nicht den
regierungsanspruch reklamieren aber ich
mache parallel und da wird das ganz
paradox ich leite jetzt schon den
Übergang zu einer anderen Führung der
CDU ein und will das anschließend
moderieren das Moderieren hat schon im
Falle von Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer
nicht funktioniert das war genau der
gleiche Anspruch ich moderiere ich führe
weiter von vorne das ist völlig obsolet
und ist eine Sache die eine
ankündigungsprozer ist er ist in dem
Augenblick und ich meine es ist der vom
heutigen Tage endgültig Armin ohne Land
weil er gesagt hat ich werde dem
Erneuerungsprozess in keinster Weise im
Wege stehen damit ist natürlich auch der
Anspruch Kanzler noch mal zu werden oder
wirklich zu werden in der Annahme man
könnte ihn erwählen gleichsam ist quasi
obsolet er hat sich ein Fenster gelassen
aber das hat er sich gleichsam mit dem
mit der Ankündigung eines übrigens
Parteitages im Dezember zugeschlagen
wird die Erneuerung stattfinden und das
ist eine ohne Armin Laschet man wie
würden sie es bewerten sie
kennen die CDU sie haben mit Wahlkampf
gemacht mit der CDU was war das jetzt
heute war das sozusagen ein Aufbäumen
noch mal gegen Markus Söder der ja
gestern die
Tür eigentlich zugeschlagen hat zu
jamaika ist das so ein so ein Mann gegen
Mann Show oder was haben wir da gesehen
es war die Erkenntnis es gibt einen Film
letzte Ausfahrt Brooklyn die letzte
Ausfahrt für den Hauptausgang sonst
hätte durch den lieferantenausgang gehen
müssen das hatte erkannt ich glaube
nicht nur durch eigene Erkenntnis
sondern ist hat ein paar im nahestehende
gegeben die ihm den guten Rat gegeben
haben Armin Wolfgang Bosbach war einer
davon aber auch intern wolfgang hat ja
keine Funktion mehr in der CDU aber
andere haben eben auch gesagt es geht
nicht mehr weiter und das Wort würde und
Selbstachtung ist von Markus Söder auch
genannt worden wenn wir so weitermachen
und uns quasi der FDP an die Brust
schmeißen dann verlieren wir beides
davon wäre es dann eine klarer Rückzug
heute zu sagen ich trete jetzt zurück
von allen Ämtern wäre das nicht das der
klarere Schritt gewesen ja als wäre der
wurde vollere vielleicht auch
klarere Schritt gewesen aber nicht der
Machbare weil dann hätte er die CDU in
ein Chaos gestürzt weil dann wäre die
nachtelangen Messer auf längere Wochen
oder Monate ausgedehnt worden so hat er
noch quasi
ich bin nicht so wie bei ihnen so
negativ das moderierende ich glaube auch
dass man ihm das lässt das ist auch eine
seiner Stärken Höhe ich immer wieder in
Nordrhein-Westfalen dass er das
Moderieren kann und ich glaube er bringt
das jetzt in ein ruhiges Fahrwasser man
muss die Satzung der CDU kennen man kann
nicht einfach so schnell Parteitag
einberufen da müssen mindestens drei
Landesverbände das fordern das sind
viele Kommentatoren unterwegs die kennen
diese Satzung nicht müssen sie auch
nicht aber dann dürfen sie auch nicht
drüber schreiben okay also das ist aus
meiner aus meiner Sicht es war ein letzt
letzte Möglichkeit und er wird das jetzt
auch machen trotzdem geht natürlich im
Hintergrund genau da reden wir gleich
mal drüber aber erst bleiben wir noch
mal bei dem Tag heute bei dem
Ereignissen heute Herr Salazar wir haben
sie das wahrgenommen dass sowohl als
auch von Herr Laschet der zum einen zu
sagen ich stehe nicht im Weg auf der
anderen Seite stehe ich auch noch zur
Verfügung das ist ja eine doppelte
Botschaft eigentlich
hat man auch schon gesagt hat das ist ja
auch
die moderierende Art die Armin Laschet
hat und ich sehe das ein bisschen anders
auch als Herr von Lucke das ist also es
steht ja mehr auf dem Spiel für die CDU
als die Karriere von Armin Laschet und
das hat er glaube ich ziemlich klar
gesagt das ist darum geht diese Partei
aufzustellen und auch hoffentlich zu
verjüngen jungen er hat auch darüber
gesprochen über Kandidaten oder keine
Kandidatin also das hat er insofern
offengelassen und ich glaube die Partei
wird gut daran tun auch eine
entsprechende Diskussion jetzt zu führen
die jetzt nicht so also kontrovers ist
ja okay und gut aber nicht so verletzend
und wie war wie die letzten drei Jahren
dann sagen wir so die Kontroversen oder
bzw die
Wahlen zu den jeweiligen Vorsitzenden
und die Nachbeben dieser Wahlen waren
jetzt nicht unbedingt befrieden für die
Partei das heißt er hat ein klares
Signal gesandt dass er das gerne
moderieren möchte aber gleichzeitig auch
ein Signal gesandt an alle Ländern die
quasi jetzt auch Ambitionen haben dass
Sie bitte auch eine beschriebene Wirkung
in die Partei hineinbringen sollten denn
der bitter viele Leute die die Zukunft
gestalten können ja aber er ist doch
jemand
an ihm entzündet sich doch jetzt ganz
viel die Leute sind doch sind ganz viele
sind wirklich frustriert in dieser
Partei es haben viele ihr Mandat
verloren ist er wirklich der richtige
dass man sagt er soll diese Partei jetzt
irgendwie in Ruhe zu einem zu einem
anderen zu erneuern
also er hat ja gesagt dass er die diese
diesen Prozess moderieren wird erneuern
erneuert wird dann sobald es einen neuen
Vorstand gibt also das und das müssen
alle anderen auch zu gemeinsam anpacken
meines Erachtens gehört eine Verjüngung
dazu ich meine ist ja nicht so dass die
Partei jetzt nur
ältere Leute hat das ist ja junge
Ministerpräsidenten von Tobias Hans über
Daniel Günther zur Michael Kretschmer
und natürlich der Gesundheitsminister
Jens Spahn da sind ja viele Personen die
die in Verantwortung kommen können und
wenn diese Generation an einem Strang
zieht und auch zusammen ist in der
ganzen Breite jetzt von Michael
Kretschmer bist du Daniel Günther und
Sarah Bühler bis zur Karsten Linnemann
wenn das ein als Team aufgestellt wird
dann hat das auch eine Chance auf 2025
oder 2029
jetzt in diesem Jahr nach dieser Wahl
Frau Gaschke sie sind sie waren mal
Kieler Oberbürgermeisterin und sind dann
auch zurückgetreten und da gab es auch
viel Ärger und es war etwas ja war eine
schwierige Zeit natürlich auch für Sie
sie haben darüber auch ein Buch
geschrieben volles Risiko haben sie das
gesagt wenn man in die Politik geht wie
schwer ist es zurückzutreten und
verstehen Sie dass Herr Laschet heute
gesagt nicht klar gesagt hat ich trete
zurück
es ist tatsächlich eine schwierige Frage
ich selber habe es nicht schwer gefunden
zurückzutreten zu einem Zeitpunkt wo ich
das Gefühl hatte ich werde durch die
Skandalisierung eines Problems
[Musik]
dass meinem Amt abgehalten also ich kann
gar nicht für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
in Kiel mehr in dem Maße da sein indem
ich es hätte sein müssen und dann
sozusagen es gab einen medienteen nur
der vollkommen negativ war und den man
nicht überwinden konnte insofern ist mir
dann irgendwie dieser diese Bilanzierung
relativ leicht gefallen weil Laschet ist
es natürlich etwas schwieriger ich finde
er hätte eigentlich gleich nach der Wahl
sozusagen signalisieren müssen es gibt
einen Wahlsieger das ist Olaf Scholz es
gibt Parteien die haben die Wahl
erkennbar gewonnen die Union gehört
nicht dazu und insofern diesen Anspruch
also noch eine Jamaika-Koalition bilden
zu wollen ich kann das sozusagen
einerseits aus machtaktischen Gründen
verstehen nobler und auch klüger glaube
ich wäre es gewesen zu sagen nein das
ist jetzt wir sind jetzt hier nicht in
der ersten Reihe wir haben nicht den
ersten Auftrag zur Regierungsbildung und
die CDU hat ja in der Tat also dringend
und deswegen bin ich wirklich auch so
einen Schritt vorher Salazar noch
zurückgehen also bevor man jetzt auch
die junge Generation und wie können
wieder macht Optionen aussehen also die
CDU muss ich jetzt wirklich mal mit
ihrer Vergangenheit beschäftigen und
muss irgendwie ein Verhältnis zu ihrer
Merkel entwickeln und das wird sicher
sehr spannend da werden die jungen
gefragt sein aber das ist auch eine
große Aufgabe und die Frage ist ja auch
wie sehr jetzt im Moment die Wunden da
sind also der Gesundheitsminister aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen Laumann hat zum
Beispiel gesagt es beschäftigt mich wie
hier die politische Vernichtung eines
Menschen stattfindet und er redet von
Armin Laschet das ist bitter ich finde
so muss die politische
Auseinandersetzung nicht sein also was
wie in welchem Zustand ist die Union mit
Armin Laschet jetzt naja wir erleben
momentan
Koch mal das schöne Wort ist brutalst
möglichen genannt wie brutalst möglich
mit einem aber auch historischen Wald
Verlierer abgerechnet wird und ich
glaube wir dürfen uns die Brutalitäten
in dieser Union nicht zu sanft
vorstellen ich meine übrigens bewusst
die gesamte Union
brutalst möglich hat natürlich derjenige
agiert als erster der das Vakuum in der
Union festgestellt hat nämlich Markus
Söder wenn wir uns an die Worte von
gestern erinnern mit denen er sagte man
sollte sich mit dem Ergebnis endlich
anfreunden man müsste den realitäts
aufbringen dann war das Wort anfreunden
von einem solchen Zynismus geprägt den
faktisch bedeutete es nichts anderes als
zu sagen lieber Armin Laschet akzeptiere
dass du Geschichte bist und das war der
große Unterschied Markus Söder der einen
großen Anteil an der Niederlage von
Armin Laschet hat er hat ihn während des
Wahlkampf systematisch mit
reduziert mit attackiert kein gutes Wort
in teilnehmen müssen ich glaube durchaus
aus einem nachvollziehbaren Grund weil
er gewusst hätte mit ihm hätte man die
Wahl gewonnen davon bin ich überzeugt
ich glaube tatsächlich Markus Söder
hätte weit größere Chancen gehabt es gab
dann aber eine Unfähigkeit seinerseits
zu akzeptieren dass sich die CDU mit
aller Brutalität ihrerseits gegenüber
Söder durchgesetzt hat und das hat er
Laschet während des gesamten Wahlkampfs
spüren lassen und ich bin ziemlich
sicher die 2%. die Laschet verloren hat
und die ihn letztlich hinter ähm Scholz
hat haben einlaufen lassen die hätte er
durchaus haben können wenn sich ein
Söder ganz klar an seine Seite gestellt
wir haben ein Wahlkampf von Söder gegen
Laschet erlebt und gestern sagte ihm
eindeutig äh jetzt freunde dich endlich
mit dem Ergebnis an in dem Wissen darum
dass er natürlich als Ministerpräsident
von Bayern das Vakuum vor allem in
Bayern wollen Markus Söder hat eine
eigene Rechnung die tendiert dahin dass
ihm auch die Ampel deswegen diese klare
Absage an die Ampel dass ihm die Ampel
gar nicht von Bedeutung war er will weit
lieber ein oppositionswahlkampf gegen
eine hochschwierige Konstellation in
Berlin mit drei Parteien bei denen
keiner weiß wie es funktioniert er hat
eine ganz klare Ausrichtung ich gewinne
23 besser die Bayern war jetzt ein
Revolution und deswegen will ich ein
letztes sagen diese Situation des
Vakuums das jetzt in der CDU herrscht da
würde ich an Salazar sehr widersprechen
das heißt ich kann mir beim besten
Willen nicht vorstellen dass das eine
Amt was die CDU noch zur Verfügung hat
das ist nämlich das Amt des
Parteivorsitzenden und wahrscheinlich in
Personalunion mit dem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden dass das eine
einvernehmliche Lösung gibt dann würde
mich die Union nach all den
Streitigkeiten über die letzten Jahre
haben sehr überraschen es übersteigt
meine Fantasie oder so oft gesagt es
würde mich wundern wenn es nicht ein
knallhartes macht Kalkül und Gerangel
gibt und da gibt es keine
einvernehmliche Aufstellung da gibt es
einen knallharten Machtkampf in
kürzester Zeit und ich nehme an den wird
auch Armin Laschet nicht moderiert
don't go on the kitchen das weiß jeder
der in die Politik geht erstens zweitens
um 18 Uhr das war eine halbe Stunde
bevor die Pressekonferenz mit Laschet
anberauben war hat der Clue der
innenpolitische Sprecher der FDP quasi
einen Nachruf schon über Twitter
losgelassen sie haben so viel für das
Gemeinwesen getan und es ist alles so
toll und so schön Freunde wir sind in
der Politik schaut euch mal die
Wahlkämpfe in Amerika an dann ist das
hier Kindergeburtstag also keine
falschen Tränen bitte
ich möchte keine Wahlkämpfe haben wie in
Amerika ich finde es ganz schön dass das
bei uns normalerweise etwas
zivilisierter zugeht und zweiter Punkt
hat natürlich Recht was die Rolle von
Markus Söder angeht aber wir dürfen
glaube ich da also auch als Medien
Menschen nicht ganz von der Rolle der
Medien absehen was Laschet angeht also
dem ist tatsächlich eine Ablehnung
entgegengeschlagen die nicht überrascht
hat also ich würde jetzt vielleicht
nicht so weit gehen es Hass zu nennen
aber es war schon sehr sehr unfreundlich
hat mich immer gefragt bekommen diese
starken Emotionen diesen Mann gegenüber
überhaupt her der ist doch gar nicht
schlimm also der ist halt nicht
vernünftig man kann ihn vielleicht nicht
wahnsinnig toll finden man kann
vielleicht finden dass er manchmal seine
Meinung etwas
opportunistisch geändert hat alles
Sachen die man vernünftig kritisieren
kann aber da waren also Begriffe also
die tatsächlich von Journalisten
verwendet worden sind also die eigenen
Leute entsorgen ihn klein dick
du Armin jetzt lass uns in Ruhe und so
weiter also der Ton also viele
Veröffentlichungen war schon genauso
unfreundlich oder schlimmer als der der
Parteifreunde und des politischen
Gegners und das finde ich jetzt auch
noch eine Frage die einfach spannend und
offen ist woher kam dieser unglaubliche
anti-lasche ist ich habe so ein zwei
Vermutungen
der war ja auch also die
antilasche-stimmung wurde ja auch z.B
aus Bayern von Markus Söder sehr klar
durch diese Auseinandersetzung der
Kanzlerkandidaten man wurde doch auch
dadurch befeuert Herr Salazar
ja auch aber nicht nur also es ist ja
auch vom politischen Gegner also wenn
man sich jetzt auch anguckt wie auf
Social wieder das befeuert wurde mit
welchen Hashtags teilweise organisiert
also wenn das wenn Korrektiv jetzt auch
das kurz vor der Wahl auch
veröffentlicht hat wie die gezeigt haben
wie das über WhatsApp Gruppen teilweise
organisiert wurde das war jetzt schon
ziemlich schäbig teilweise weil man auch
sagen muss klar deshalb sagst du wohl
Herr Luca als auch Herr Hartmann das ist
natürlich alles kein Ponyhof es hätte
die CDU auch besser organisieren können
also die die gegenwehren Social Media
und da hätte es natürlich geholfen schon
einig zu sein und
noch mal das Thema Ponyhof doch mal zu
Herrn Luke natürlich wird es da ein
Machtkampf geben natürlich wird es auch
wird es auch
unterschiedliche Interessensgruppen
geben die sich zusammenführen werden
aber trotzdem
am Ende des Tages werden die sich als
Team zusammenraufen müssen und wenn man
ein größ das letzte Mal dann
schlagkräftiges Team
gewinnt dann dann hat man dann hat man
auch die Chance auf mehr Einigkeit denn
man sich die SPD anschaut vielleicht die
haben ja gewonnen weil sie die Einigkeit
die eben gezeigt haben die Union hat das
in den letzten sechs Monaten gar nicht
also so gar nicht gezählt
die SPD hat sozusagen jetzt drei
Menschen nämlich eine Doppelspitze als
Partei im Parteivorsitz und ein
Kanzlerkandidaten und bei der CDU geht
es aber doch eigentlich immer nur um
eine Figur her hat man oder wer ist für
sie der nächste starke kommende Mann der
CDU wer kann jetzt wenn Herr Laschet den
Weg frei macht diese Partei erneuern
also mein Favorit war von Anfang an
Friedrich Merz ich wohne seit zwei
Jahren in Leipzig im Osten gab es nur
Friedrich Merz das war auch das
Wahlergebnis eines eine Folge davon im
Osten ich glaube auch jetzt wenn es
diese breite Grundlage der Wahl gibt
wenn es wirklich diese
Mitgliederbefragung möglicherweise gibt
aus dem Kreisverbänden heraus ist mein
Favorit
März
mein heimlicher wunschwerk Carsten
Linnemann ah da mache ich kein Held raus
weil ich befreundet bin und es gibt ja
nur zwei posten wenn die CDU CSU in der
Opposition ist die zu verteilen sind das
ist der Vorsitzende der dann natürlich
Opposition führen wird und der Beruf
seinen Generalsekretär mehr gibt es
nicht mehr zu verteilen
normalerweise vor einer Voraussetzung
sein die zwei gibt es und da wäre dann
mein Mann Carsten Linnemann und dann
würde die CDU auch wieder langsam
anrollen aber wieder schnell in Fahrt
kommen nein also
der alleine schon die Tatsache das
Friedrich Merz der ja zunächst einmal
sagte ganz bemerkenswerterweise ein
drittes Mal trete ich nicht mehr an wir
müssen es ja bewusst machen wir haben es
hier bei den Kandidaten sind ja nicht so
viele sind übrigens alles
nordrhein-westfälische Männer die wir
alle kennen der nicht Verlierer unter
den vieren die dabei im Rennen sind ist
Herr Brinkmann
aus März hat dreimal verloren kann man
sagen gegen Merkel das ist lange her das
ist 20 Jahre her da war er also
derjenige der Fraktionsvorsitzender war
Helmut Kohl auch ja die haben aber eine
gewisse Kontinuität des Siegens und
eines steigerns gehabt bei märz wird man
sagen müssen er hat dreimal verloren
gegen Merkel gegen Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer und Abschluss gegen
Laschet und das Herr Merz nur die
Erneuerung wäre die Herr Laschet und
heute angekündigt hat wird man mit Fug
und Recht nicht so ohne weiteres
behaupten können also insofern ist er
eine Erneuerung in den Positionen und
Inhalt die Frage ist nur ja vielleicht
das ist wohl wahr er ist jedenfalls eine
klare eher nach wirtschaftsliberal
konservativ mit mit Ja sagen wir mal
also
konservativ im Sinne des das eher
altertümlichen also nicht gerade im
Sinne eines eines wertkonservativen
vielleicht grüner Natur oder sowas was
eben interessanterweise auch Söder eher
verkörpert deswegen sind ja größte
antiposensöhne und März immer gewesen
März war mit der Verhinderer mit
Wolfgang Schäuble natürlich derjenige
der im Kern gegen Söder war also März
glaube ich ist nun wahrlich nicht das
aufproduzieren aber und das wollte ich
vor allem sagen wenn März jetzt sagt ich
bin geneigt nicht wieder nicht die
regierten zu stellen aber ich betreibe
eine Abstimmung durch die Basis ist das
natürlich genau das Gegenteil von einer
einvernehmlichen Lösung das wird dann
natürlich die dezidierte lang
ausgetragene Auseinandersetzung über
Vorstellungsrunden und dergleichen da
kann ich mir beim besten Willen eben
nicht vorstellen
einer moderierenden von Garner von Armin
Laschet moderierten Teambildung kommt
das wird die erste Frage Friedrich Merz
hat heute direkt getwittert nach dieser
Pressekonferenz und hat getwitter ich
zitiere mal Armin Laschet macht heute
den Weg frei für den Neuanfang der CDU
dafür verdient er der Respekt Dank und
Anerkennung ich werde mich nach Kräften
daran beteiligen dafür ein
einvernehmlichen Weg zu den der auch
Zustimmung unserer Mitgliedern
uns an die ganze Friedlichkeit da sei
nur dran erinnert das Friedrich
Merzenich damals sagte ich bin von
absolut populistischer Manier ich bin
von Partei ist wirklich man verhindert
worden ich bin der Mann der Basis ich
bin mit dem schönen Wort von Dortmund
aufnimmt ich bin der Kandidat der Herzen
so das ist jetzt die Ankündigung wenn es
so geht ich werde eine basische sagen
oder nicht werden
ja wir reden doch von es ist doch klar
Jens Spahn ist im Rennen
März Röntgen und die meisten Pläne waren
das sind doch die die ständig werden
aus der Fraktion etwas anderes ja das
glaube ich auch nicht so also die
gehören dazu aber wir sehen uns doch
einig dass es aus dem Kreis kommt und
danach werden sie das ist doch immer so
gewesen danach wird eine auf dem Hof
sein der wird es dann sein
in welche Richtung die Partei dann geht
also es geht ja in dieser wahrscheinlich
nicht nur weil um die personelle sondern
auch um die inhaltliche kursbestimmung
noch mal Frau Gaschke was würden Sie
denn sagen bei den ganzen Team ist ja
nicht eine Frau dabei
ja das fände ich jetzt nicht so ein
großes Problem die CDU hatte ja nun ich
glaube insgesamt 18 19 Jahre alles
Vorsitzende also ja 16 Jahre Kanzlerin
ja okay genau davon muss sie sich
vielleicht auch erstmal wieder erholen
also wahrscheinlich ging es jetzt auch
mal mit einem Mann zwischendurch die
interessante Frage ist ja wirklich in
welche Richtung will sie politisch gehen
und ich finde märz kann schon für Sie in
Anspruch nehmen dass er jeweils knapp
verloren hat und das ist natürlich an
der Basis eine Stimmung gab die ihm
durchaus zugeneigt war insofern ich weiß
nicht was jetzt verwerflich daran sein
soll wenn die CDU ihr Problem auch im im
Wege der basisbefragung löst das hat die
SPD ja schließlich auch gemacht nicht
also mit einem unglaublichen das haben
wir nur schon wieder vergessen weil das
so lange her also aber auch eine
Überraschung bei der SPD Kandidaten
Zirkus und wurden zwei Leute also es
wurde genau nicht der jetzt Kanzler ins
B ne sondern es wurden andere Leute bei
denen man jetzt ganz froh ist dass sie
sich ein bisschen zurückhalten im Moment
jedenfalls darüber froh zu sein also
insofern ist doch die Frage in welche
Richtung will die politisch gehen und da
ist natürlich immer die Frage also und
den Weg hat ja anscheinend auch Laschet
gewählt also noch grüner und als erstes
also Grüne im Kompetenzteam vorstellen
und so kann sein dass eine Menge
CDU-Basis und auch ehemalige CDU-Wähler
gerne was klassisch konservativeres
hätten und auch da wäre es natürlich
nicht der schlechteste Aufbruch
ja genau sie sind ja wir sind der
Kommunikationsprofi also was wer für Sie
so die zu sagen ein claim wie man
heutzutage sagt also eine Botschaft und
womit die CDU nach vorne gehen kann und
sagen kann dafür stehen wir
also es geht ja auch um ein modernen
moderne Ausprägung des Konservatismus
und wir haben ja ich meine bei aller
Kritik an Markus Söder auf der sozusagen
wir mit Armin das Studium gegangen ist
was nicht geht also er zeigt er auch in
Bayern sozusagen dass man auch den
Aufbruch Wagen muss sozusagen auch was
Themen angeht und ist da würde ich Frau
Gaschke widersprechen ich glaube das
Thema Ökologie hat die Union einfach
verschlafen und auch gesagt sie hat
jetzt kein und keine Lösungen wir wollen
sie ach ja nee irgendwann wird das
gemacht und man hat das nicht so richtig
angepackt also Merkel hat das 2005 dann
vielleicht auch mal postuliert aber dann
irgendwie in die in die Schublade gelegt
und dieses Thema kann sich der an diesem
Thema nicht verschließen und was noch
mal das personalentiert klar ich glaube
ich glaube dass natürlich die alten
Themen wieder aufbrechen wenn aber ist
jeder oder jede Vorsitzende jeder
Vorsitzende wird dann auch entsprechend
integrieren müssen also ich glaube
sozusagen auch wenn es jetzt für Herz
oder Kasten Lindemann wäre die würden
dann auch entsprechend auch in andere
Flügel hinein integrieren müssen aber
ich möchte noch mal wiederholen also es
geht jetzt nicht um eine Aufstellung
sozusagen die wo die wie die Union jetzt
quasi jetzt die nächsten zwei Jahre aber
es geht jetzt darum 2025 20029 das
Wissen in dessen müssen sich die Leute
bewusst sein und wenn man damit einem
Vorsitzenden oder einer möglichen
Kandidaten reingeht der ist in den
nächsten beiden spätestens bei der
übernächsten Ball über 70 ist weiß ich
nicht ob das quasi gegen relativ frische
Kräfte wie Annalena baerbock oder wer
auch immer Scholz folgen wird von Erfolg
gekrönt sein wird also immer meines
Erachtens ist die Generation der jetzt
40 um die 40-jährigen dran genau und wie
realistisch ist denn das was Herr
Laschet heute noch mal so klar gesagt er
möchte doch gerne Jamaika er sagt das
ist das Beste für unser Land und er
heilt eigentlich hält die Türen offen
also ist das gibt's da irgend noch eine
Chance Herr hat man glauben sie da noch
dran das gab von Anfang an nicht dran
geglaubt und ich halte das festhalten es
gibt ja Kommentatoren die sagen ah das
stärkt die FDP in den Verhandlungen
damit Sie möglichst dann als Bremse in
dieser ampelkombination mögliche
konservative Themen dafür steht es ist
doch nicht die Aufgabe der Union die FDP
zu stärken also ich muss doch
zusammenrechnen und wenn ich dann sage
es geht wohl nicht und Lasche denke ich
hat aus der FDP jetzt den Wink bekommen
dass die sich immer näher kommen die
Zeichen sprechen ja dafür das war glaube
ich auch ein Grund warum wir heute den
Schritt gemacht hat dann ist das die
Faktor tot so wie das Markus Söder sagt
und der Juri ist es Ende der Woche tot
ja aber wie das denkt ja jeder und auch
wenn man bei Umfragen nach Umfragen
schaut will die Mehrheit der Wählerinnen
und Wähler wollen eben die Ampel und
nicht Jamaika warum stellt sich dann
trotzdem jemand hin und sagt wir machen
Jamaika das ist besser für unser Land
hello ist ein Funken des Überlebens für
Armin Laschet ja beinhaltet es ist ja
nicht so dass er gänzlich die letzte
Hoffnung preisgeben wollte das ist ja
die am seiner heutigen Aussage ich stehe
für Erneuerung der Union aber ich stehe
weiterhin bereit wenn alles umkippt das
hat er anders gehalten als Markus Söder
und übrigens aus einem klaren Kalkül es
geht für ihn ums politische Überleben es
könnte ja sein das darf man ja nicht
völlig ausschließen man es gibt alles um
und die Verkleidung dass er das für das
Land gemacht hat nun gut das ist Prosa
es ist was ganz anderes hoch spannend
und da hat weil man was sehr spannendes
gesagt Markus Söder hat ganz bewusst der
die Absage an Jamaika auch erteilt um
die FDP nicht zu stärken das eigentliche
Phänomen ist doch mit der Ausrichtung
der CDU und CSU gemeinsam sie haben
größte Sorge dass sie den Platz der
ökonomischen Vernunft in der Mitte des
Parteienspektrums denn der ist jetzt
erstmal verloren dass sie ihn
langfristig ein Stück weit erstens an
die FDP verlieren die neue Rolle der FDP
wird es sein die Tassen im Schrank zu
lassen mit dem alten Wort von Karl
Schiller dafür zu sorgen dass rote und
grüne nicht gewissermaßen über Bord eine
eine ökologische Politik machen sie
sorgen für die ökolog für die
ökonomische Vernunft das ist die Rolle
die hat Lindner gestern noch nicht
annehmen wollen weil er so verdattert
war dass ihm Söder quasi den die Tür
vor die Tür gesetzt habe aber sie können
diese Rolle natürlich übernehmen und da
will natürlich Söder die FDP nicht noch
in der Verhandlungsposition stärken und
das ist das eigentliche Problem die CDU
muss doch jetzt in einer völlig neuen
Situation das was sie über 16 Jahre mit
dem großen Wort die Mitte in hohem Maße
für sich reklamieren konnte das muss sie
in einer Konstellation des
Schlagabtausch mit einer AFD auf dem
rechten Rand muss sie diesen Anspruch
erheben irgendwie wieder hinzukommen und
Söder geht ein völlig das sei nur gesagt
ein völlig anderen Weg als als Friedrich
Merz eine ganz kurz Friedrich Merz geht
ein antiökologischen Weg er geht einen
Weg der dezidiert er hat Fridays for
future als fast idiotisch gekennzeichnet
er hat also ein absolut Anti gegen die
jugendgerichteten Weg natürlich mit dem
Versuch weil immer getönt ich werde der
AFD die Stimmen abnehmen ob das nun
funktioniert Söder geht da einen Wald
klügeren Weg das heißt die Konkurrenz
existiert
wir müssen ein progressiv wir müssen
auch progressiven Kurs machen dir das
ökologische Thema auch wirklich ernst
nimmt ist natürlich anders beantwortet
die Grünen aber es ernst zu nehmen dazu
gehören auch zu Jamaika die Grünen die
werden da völlig außer Acht gelassen
wenn die wenn die FDP mögliche Rückkehr
Gedanken hat die Grünen haben die noch
lange nicht sie werden sie alle vier der
Meinung Herr Salazar und Frau gaschka
das Jamaika gar keine Chance mehr hat
glauben Sie das gibt es da noch
irgendeine Chance
es könnte noch eine Chance geben aber
ich halte sie für sehr gering aber er
wir müssen also die FDP geht da unter
gewissen Schmerzen rein das ist schon
das ist schon so also ich sehe immer
noch nicht wie das gerade Wirtschafts-
und finanzpolitisch das SPD und das
fdp-programm übereinander gelegt werden
können und für die Grünen ist das auch
zwar irgendwie habituell näher aber ich
meine die sind ja auch in ihrer
Entwicklung einige Jahre jetzt
zurückgeworfen denn
in einer Jamaika-Koalition könnte Robert
Habeck 2025 als Kanzlerkandidat der
linken Mitte Antreten in der
Ampelkoalition ist der Kanzlerkandidat
den linken Mitte der amtierende Kanzler
der linken Mitte also das wird da auch
für die Grünen nicht so leicht ist über
alle Parteien nicht so einfach insofern
darf sich die SPD freuen okay dass sie
alle schon so weit voraus gucken jetzt
muss man erstmal gucken dass das jetzt
hinkriegen braucht frau Gaschke was
glauben sie gibt so eine Chance auf
Jamaika beziehungsweise wenn man jetzt
sagt er Laschet hat heute gesagt die SPD
ist ein der Partner und deshalb ist es
für unser Land das muss FDP und grün
müssen werden die sehen dass die SPD
kein guter Partner da ist also wie sehr
sehen Sie dann noch eine Möglichkeit
dass das noch funktionieren kann dass
eben dadurch dass die ampelscheitert
nein also die Ampel wird sicher
schwierig und das wird spannend zu sehen
vielleicht hält sie auch nicht die ganze
Legislaturperiode aber für Jamaika sehe
ich jetzt im Moment gar keine Chancen
mehr die Grünen werden wahnsinnig wenn
sie das machen würden die haben bei
ihren Wählern ich glaube 92 Prozent
Zustimmung für für die Ampelkoalition
laut Politbarometer sind inzwischen da
die Dinge nun so sind wie sie sind
glaube ich drei Viertel 76 Prozent für
Scholz als Kanzler also dafür spricht
alles die einzigen die damit tatsächlich
inhaltliche Probleme haben dürften auch
mit ihrer Klientel das ist die FDP und
die darf sich natürlich auch nicht
völlig über den Tisch ziehen lassen also
die muss glaubwürdige Siege erringen in
dieser Konstellation da bin ich gespannt
also gerade wie das mit den Grünen gehen
wird weil für die Grünen gilt Augenhöhe
immer hauptsächlich für Sie selbst und
dann erst für alle anderen also das da
ist Sprengstoff drin aber es ist das was
jetzt erstmal kommen muss also das ist
das ist die gewählte sozusagen die
gewählte Konstellation und das Laschet
jetzt Rückzugsgefechte dafür kann ich
kann ich psychologisch gut
nachvollziehen aber das bringt jetzt
wirklich auch nichts mehr was heißt das
denn dann herr Hartmann für die CDU wenn
sie in der Opposition ist
ja sie werden sich daran denken sie
werden sich daran gewöhnen müssen
da können sie mal nachfragen in
Thüringen wieder so ist es gibt noch
andere Bundesländer
sie werden sich damit abfinden müssen
das wird nicht von heute auf morgen
gehen aber ich glaube dass das sogar die
rheinener schließen lässt denn wenn man
macht hat will man verteilen und will
mit der Macht sterben können natürlich
hast du als Opposition nicht und wenn du
wieder dahin willst und den will glaube
ich haben dann alle dann musst du die
rein schließen und ich glaube das ist
die Chance der CDU und Herr Luke glauben
Sie dass die SPD die das ja jetzt auf
einmal geschafft hat die ja jetzt auf
einmal diszipliniert wirkt und das
irgendwie hinkriegt dass das hält und
dass sie diese Ampel durchhält weil sie
muss ja dann vielleicht jetzt auch mal
irgendwas abgeben in Richtung FDP und
Grünen damit es wirklich ein stabiles
koalitionsstabile Koalition wird naja ob
es ist die ganz große Frage das ist ja
eine einerseits sehr spekulative Frage
aber wir dürfen eines nie vergessen eine
Dreierkonstellation und das macht sie so
Kardinal anders als jede
zweierkonstellation ist eine bei der
einer von den dreien ständig die
Versuchung haben kann auszubüchsen weil
die Machtverhältnis sich verändert haben
die anderen beiden bleiben auf ihn
angewiesen es gibt übrigens auch immer
die Verdachts das Verdachtsmoment zwei
könnten sich gegen den Dritten verbünden
wir erleben das beispielsweise auch in
Berlin das ist ja eine Koalition die
eigentlich sogar in einem Lager
stattfindet Rot-Grün und bei der man
nicht sagen kann dass diese drei
Parteien einträchtig miteinander
regieren sondern sich gegenseitig fast
manchmal nicht das schwarze unter den
Fingern gönnen sondern ständig in einer
Verdacht so sind könnten zwei sich gegen
mich verbünden damit bin ich sagen die
Möglichkeit dass einer der dreien sagt
so das beende ich wieder weil vielleicht
auch konkretes Beispiel FDP
2017 oder nein
ich rede jetzt ich komme zu dass sie
jetzt zustande kommt versteht sich doch
von selbst da ich dachte sie gehen schon
weiter ich dachte sie geben Sie wir
reden über die Frage ob sie dann die
nächsten vier Jahre hält natürlich kommt
die unintelligible kommt aus zwei
Gründen zustande dass einer Frau Gaschke
gesagt die Grünen können gar nicht bei
verprellung ihrer gesamten Wählerschaft
mit einer
jamaika-konstellation ankommen und dann
noch mit Armin Laschet als dem Wald
Verlierer und die FDP kann in der Tat
nicht ein zweites Mal eine Konstellation
platzen lassen das ist ihre eigenen
Wählerschaft deswegen halte ich die die
Sache für jetzt mit ziemlicher
Sicherheit gelaufen also das wäre schon
irre zumal der Rückfall dann ja nicht
Jamaika und notwendigerweise bedeuten
müsste sondern vielleicht die gleiche
Konstellation dass uns Herr Steinmeier
ein weiteres Mal sagt diesmal Gerichte
dann die cdu/csu ihr müsst die große
Koalition mit der SPD machen und wer
weiß ob die ob die cdu/csu nicht doch
einmal überlegt ob die Oppositionsrolle
mit einer AFD mit der man ungemein
aufpassen muss dass man nicht sich zu
sehr mit einer AFD kloppt um eine
vielleicht sehr kleine
rechtspopulistische Wählerschaft zu
kleiner zu machen und damit die Mitte
aus den Augen wird eine nicht sehr eine
doch ziemlich unangenehme Situation sein
kann also damit würde ich sagen diese
Ampel wird keiner scheitern lassen aber
ob sie die Jahre hält das ist echt
zweifelhaft weil das Schwierigkeiten die
auf alle drei Parteien zukommen die
imment sind und ich glaube vor allem
auch vielleicht auch noch als einen
Punkt die Grünen werden es bei ihren
Erwartungen ihrer Wählerschaft weit weit
schwerer haben als viele denken weil FDP
und SPD wären sich in ihrer
wirtschaftswachstumsorientierung sehr
ergänzen und da wird eine viel
zusammenpassen was aber mit einer eher
wachstumskritischen ökologischen
Richtung die auch gerade Fridays for
future präferiert nicht zu Leichen
Übereinstimmung zu bringen ist Herr
Salazar wenn man jetzt das sieht wie die
ersten jetzt die Pressekonferenzen nach
den Sondierungen waren da waren hat ja
ganz wenig daraus gelassen man ist dann
hält sich da sehr bedeckt aber man sagt
immer wer es ist vertrauensvoll und
entspannend und wir gehen gut
miteinander um wirkt das
glaubwürdig oder ist das erstmal jetzt
im Moment sozusagen man macht gute
Stimmung und dann muss man mal die
harten Punkte die kommen dann noch und
dann kann es auch noch mal ganz
schwierig werden
das ist zunächst einmal kommunikativen
Meisterstück also wie Gelb und Grün erst
einmal sich zusammengesetzt haben und
auch dieses Instagram selfie von den
vier verhandlerinnen und Verhandlern das
war schon sehr stark und auch dass sie
sich offensichtlich absprechen und auch
die Stille die Olaf Scholz dann erst hat
und dann kurze Auftritte das ist schon
mal sehr gut und natürlich werden die
harte Auseinandersetzungen haben
untereinander anders da müssen die alle
ihre jeweiligen Läden dann
zusammenhalten und auch mitnehmen also
ich glaube dass man jetzt im Moment
unterschätzt oder vermutlich ich glaube
Olaf Scholz nicht aber ein paar andere
Leute in der SPD unterschätzen werden
ist dass sie haben jetzt acht Jahre lang
bei Angela Merkel all das bekommen was
sie wollten unter den Zähneknirschen
Unionsfraktion und aber jetzt sind Sie
in der Lage wir wollen das Kanzleramt
haben und jetzt müssen die sehr sehr
viel abgeben inhaltlich und ob das ob
der Frieden dann auch so lang bleibt
also wenn quasi einiges an FDP halten
wirtschaftspolitisch dann auch
koalitionsprogramm wird das weiß ich
nicht dafür kenne ich die SPD auch nicht
gut genug vor mir Innenleben her aber
ich glaube ich glaube im Moment will man
alles haben und will man alles freut man
sich extrem und das Adrenalin ist noch
da aber ich weiß nicht ob das in zwei
Jahren wenn man eine feststellt oh Gott
die Vermögenssteuer haben wir jetzt doch
nicht bekommen und nächstes Jahr wird
der Solidaritätszuschlag ganz
abgeschafft und das dann noch hält das
ist die Frage und es gibt auch eine
starke jusofraktion innerhalb der
SPD-Fraktion Frau Gaschke sie haben Buch
geschrieben das heißt SPD eine Partei
zwischen Burnout und Euphorie das jetzt
im Moment ist man im Stadium Euphorie
wie viel wie schnell ist man wieder im
Burnout also wie sehr trauen Sie Ihre
alten Partei ihre ehemalige bei der sie
ehemals Mitglied waren das zu sagen die
kriegen das diesmal wirklich hin
ja also ich traue ihnen mindestens
ebenso sehr auch zu es ist wieder nicht
hinzukriegen oder nicht über eine lange
Strecke wir dürfen ja auch nicht
vergessen die SPD kam jetzt auf dem 14
15 Prozent Keller und sie ist ja jetzt
nicht nur erfolgreich gewesen weil sie
also sich komplett verändert hätte und
ganz tolle neue Ideen gehabt hätte und
mit Olaf Scholz einen ganz neuen
überraschenden Kandidaten sondern Scholz
Boot natürlich auch ein Stück weit
Kontinuität der großen Koalition an
sozusagen Merkel mit mit anderen
sozialdemokratischen Mitteln dass das
war für viele Leute die ja die große
Koalition gut fanden in den vergangenen
Jahren die hatte ja ständig hohe
Zustimmungswerte das darf man auch nicht
vergessen also da waren gar nicht alle
so wild auf Aufbruch und Scholz hat
sozusagen die Kontinuität angeboten und
die Partei hat ihm geholfen in diesem
Wahlkampf hauptsächlich dadurch dass sie
die Klappe gehalten hat das muss man
glaube ich so ein paar Fragen und das
also nicht jeder während sie
gleichzeitig ja in der Fraktion und in
der Parteiführung einen Linksruck
gemacht hat das ist ganz besonders
deutlich zu sehen glaube ich in der
Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik aber
natürlich auch sozialpolitischen Themen
und ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt alles
abgeräumt ist ich glaube all diese
Sachen werden wieder zum Vorschein
kommen sobald man in die Tagesarbeit
geht und man hat eine Fraktion mit ich
weiß ich glaube ich 40 50
Zusammenarbeit natürlich auch in den uso
Gremien jetzt vorher kennen das heißt
die werden schon einen Machtfaktor in
der Fraktion sein nun muss man sehen wer
der neue Fraktionsvorsitzende wird damit
sie nicht hat ja andere Ambitionen aber
nachdem was man hört wird das ja auch
eher aus der parlamentarischen linken
vermutlich besetzt werden und das ist
schon etwas was Olaf Scholz dann wieder
befrieden muss nicht also der muss
einerseits mit Christian Lindner
klarkommen von der FDP der gesagt hat
eigentlich gar keine Steuererhöhung und
dann hat er eben seinen linken Flügel
der da ganz klare Vorstellungen hat wo
er sich das Geld holen und und wie er es
umverteilen will also darauf bin ich
auch sehr gespannt und gut nun ist stolz
auch jemand der sagt wer bei mir Führung
bestellt der bekommt auch Führung jetzt
werden wir mal gucken ob die SPD selbst
bei ihr profilführung bestellt hat
nicht der erste SPD-Kanzler der aus dem
eigenen Reihen erlebt wird nämlich alle
bisher okay gut da muss man darauf
aufpassen muss mal gucken er hat man sie
sie wohnen in Leipzig und sie waren da
auch viel im Wahlkampf unterwegs jetzt
hatten wir gesehen gerade in Sachsen
Thüringen hat die AFD hohe Zugewinne
gemacht hat die CDU sehr viel verloren
wenn wir da noch mal drauf schauen auf
dieses Verhältnis Ost und West und auch
die die Regierungsbildung der Ampel oder
Jamaika was würden Sie sagen was wäre da
ein gutes Rezept damit die CDU da wieder
Land bekommt das hat
Michael Kretschmer vorgemacht bei der
Landtagswahl da war im April die AFD mit
27 Prozent vor der CDU mit 24 Prozent
ich weiß dass deswegen noch so genau was
ich da eingestiegen bin und dann hat
Michael Kretschmann einen Wahlkampf
gemacht der unmenschlich war der war
wirklich 24 Stunden am Tag sieben Tage
die Woche und ist bei den Leuten gewesen
es ist ganz wichtig gewesen dass er zu
den Menschen gegangen ist
das hat das ganze umgedreht diese
persönliche ganz persönliche Einsatz um
das ist jetzt auch das wichtige die
Thüringer CDU ist in sich so zerstritten
da wird auf
mittelfristig langfristig nichts mehr
passiert
299 Wahlkreise und wir reden über einem
Menschen der nicht mal gewählt worden
ist ich glaube man hätte gelassener
damit ja aber gelassener damit umgehen
können und einfach die Antwort geben
dass das sind Wähler entscheiden müssen
dass wir in den Medien entscheiden dass
das die Wähler entscheidend die haben
entschieden wir haben auf Platz drei hat
keine Rolle gespielt also ich meine der
persönliche Einsatz und das Gefühl wir
dürfen mitspielen was jetzt Laschet
gemacht hat
Barbara Klebsch die ist jetzt Ministerin
für Kultur und Tourismus wurde aber im
zukunftste als sozial eingestellt weil
sie beim letzten Mal
Sozialpolitik gemacht hat das war auf
dem reichsbrett entworfen das war eine
Nummer eine Luftnummer die ist geplatzt
kein Mensch redet mir davon das merken
die Ostdeutschen auch wir waren hier nur
in der bauernreihe vorne dran zum
Vorzeigen man muss sich um den Osten
kümmern ich habe die Seele dieser
Menschen dort kennengelernt in den zwei
Jahren ich habe das vorher auch nicht
immer verstanden ich habe auch mal über
Jammer Ossis gesprochen die wissen warum
sie so denken und da musst du sie holen
und noch Einsatz dazu du kannst im Osten
als CDU die Wahl nicht gewinnen aber du
kannst sie verlieren okay
was würden Sie sagen ist das ein Punkt
weil die CDU und erleichterte heute auch
angekündigt dass eine ostkonferenz geben
soll also dieser Blick in die
ostdeutschen Länder ist das ein Punkt
der wichtig ist für die Union und aber
auch vielleicht für die anderen Parteien
ja auch für alle für alle
für alle zentral aber für die Union in
ganz besonderem Maße und wenn wir heute
die Kandidaten aufgeführt haben neben
oder nachlaschet man muss es jetzt ja
schon klar sagen dann sind das alles NRW
Männer um es ganz klar zu sagen alles
klassische westdeutsche tiefste
nrw-männer und Laschet hat den ganz
großen kardinalen Fehler gemacht dass er
dieses alt fast schon adenauersche ja
für Adenauer begannt ja begann ja
bekanntlich die asiatische Steppe hinter
Magdeburg nicht das war die
Verabschiedung der DDR und und die klare
Trennlinie die er zur Westorientierung
aber Laschet hat ihn ja quasi in
europäismus noch überboten lass das an
jeder Rede gesagt ich träume sofort wenn
ich auf einer frage mich was kann ich
für Europa tun da hat sich der normale
ostdeutsche gefragt das ist nicht meine
Kardinalfrage ich brauche einen
nationale Ansprache und diese
grundsätzliche Frage bei aller
Richtigkeit Europa im Schilde zu führen
wird eine zentrale für die Union sein
vor allem für alle Parteien aber zentral
für die Union und ich habe große Zweifel
ob diese absolute NRW Dominanz die es
gegenwärtig gibt dass die richtige
Antwort ist und dann was er Salat sagt
die teamfrage absolut entscheidend zum
zum Schlagen auch wenn es ein nrw-mann
sein wird ich glaube eben nicht Herr
Günther ist der einzige der nicht aus
NRW kommt der einzige Mann am Rande
vielleicht noch erwähnt als
Ministerpräsident Herr Kretschmer wird
übrigens auch manchmal angeführt aber da
sehe ich eigentlich keine Chance dafür
ist Kretschmer auch zu eigen und
wahrscheinlich dann wieder zu sehr von
vorgetrieben also ich halte ihn dann
auch wieder zu sehr auch vielleicht zu
konservativ um die Mitte zu erzielen
aber da ein Mann aus dem Osten viel
zentrale einzubinden deutlich zu machen
wir haben einen anderen Blick auf dieses
diese Region wird gerade in der
Auseinandersetzung mit der AFD eine
absolzentrale Rolle spielen weil sonst
driftet uns der Osten in Richtung AFD
noch mehr weg und die CDU verliert dann
noch mehr an Boden ist die Frage wie sie
das schafft in der Erneuerung ganz kurz
zum Schluss noch Herr Salazar was denken
Sie also jetzt noch mal wer hat jetzt
die Autorität wem trauen sie es zu und
wie lange wird Herr Laschet dann noch
Parteivorsitzender sein
das Denken woraus wird es hinauslaufen
also
wie lange wie lange Vorsitzender wird
kann ich jetzt nicht sagen und ich
glaube unabhängig von der Person die die
Autorität haben wird es wird darauf
ankommen wirklich dass ein Team zu haben
und wirklich auch stärker auch als Team
aufzutreten ich würde gerne noch kurz
auf die das Thema Ostdeutschland angeht
die Wahl wurde in ganz Deutschland
verloren also außer das spielt eine
riesige Rolle klar aber ich würde es
auch demografisch sehen also die Bastion
der Union die älteren da haben sie
wahnsinnig verloren und das ist das hat
mit Themen wie Rente zu tun und ganz
anderen sagen klar ist absolut wichtig
wer wenn man im Osten gewinnt hat man
auch ein echte Chancen in Swing zu
machen aber es wird genauso im
Baden-Württemberg in Nordrhein-Westfalen
und in Bayern verloren aber leider kann
ich Ihnen keine klare Antwort darauf
geben der oder die nächste Vorsitzende
wird ich kann nur darauf dazu plädieren
dass es wirklich auch eher
einvernehmlich passiert
Frau graschke denken Sie das Armin
Laschet hat er sich heute durch seinen
Auftritt eigentlich mehr geschadet oder
hat alles sich noch mehr geschwächt oder
mehr gestärkt
zum Schluss ganz kurz noch ich glaube
noch also es ist wahr von also es ist es
war unglücklich es ist erst unfair
behandelt worden und das hat jetzt heute
auch nichts mehr genutzt okay also keine
schöne Schlusswort hat man oder was ein
sehr würden Sie sagen er hat sich
gestärkt dadurch ich habe die er hat die
letzte Chance genutzt mit Würde und mit
Selbstachtung und mit Anstand aus der
Nummer rauszukommen okay wir sind
gespannt wie es weitergeht haben
bestimmt nicht zum letzten Mal über die
Union und über Ampel und möglicherweise
Jamaika gesprochen hier in der Phoenix
Runde vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse hier
geht's jetzt weiter bei Phoenix der Tag
[Musik]